air conditioners and fans are lifesavers
in the heat but one of the most
impressive cooling systems is already
built into your body sweating soft
robots aren't as adaptable to the heat
they lose precision and reliability
under high temperatures until now taking
inspiration from humans researchers set
out to create an artificial muscle that
could handle heat by sweating first they
selected a material hydrogels which
contain a large volume of water were
ideal since they delay the onset of
thermal damage then researchers created
a two layered hydrogel gripper by using
what's called a stereo lithography 3d
printer this device uses light to
selectively hardened resin into a
desired structure the inner layer had a
channel in the center where pressurized
water flowed through and controlled
movement the outer layer was where the
chilling took place pores on the outer
layer connected to the inner fluid
channel to vent the liquid as the finger
touched a hot object the outer layer
expanded its pores open invented the
internal fluid while the inner layer
constricted that way the gripper
maintained its size and functionality
the system then cooled as water
evaporated off the surface this sweating
worked wonders when exposed to wind from
a fan it cooled down the system at a
rate six times faster than a non
sweating soft robot and even beat the
perspiring capabilities of humans it
also decreased the temperature of the
object being gripped without being
gripped by sweaty fingers it would have
taken longer for this brain to cool down
[Music]
since hydrogels loose structure at high
temperatures the robots ability to cool
surfaces allows the usage of soft
robotics in a wider range of
circumstances but the approach has
limitations because the fluid powering
the gripper is also used to cool it down
it takes more pressure to power movement
at higher temperatures in the future
this impressive capacity to regulate
temperature could help soft robotics
operate in extreme environments or
include other bio-inspired functions
like secreting pheromones chemicals that
elicit behavioral responses and animals
whatever wild applications come to
fruition sweating robots are simply too
cool to ignore
[Laughter]
[Music]